ساوند ستور في الرياض اضواء الجونا تسطع
بلا صخب شيرين عبد الوهاب تنفصل مجددا عن
حسام حبيب وتنضم لقائمه ثنائيات فنيه كتبت
نهايتها في
[موسيقى]
2023 سينما من اجل الانسانيه بعيدا عن
اجواء الصخب الاعلامي التي اعتادت كبت
دوراته السابقه وبحضور نخبه من النجوم
المصريين والعرب انطلقت فعاليات الدوره
السادسه من مهرجان الجونا السينمائي بعد
تاجيلها مرتين بسبب الاوضاع في غزه خلص
الحكي شو بعد
[موسيقى]
بقول خلص البيكي والقلب
مشرو وسجل مقدم الحفل الفنان المصري محمود
حميده موقفا لافتا برفضه ان يطلب من
الجمهور دقيقه صمت على ارواح الضحايا
مكتوب هنا ان اطلب من حضراتكم ان تقفوا
حداد
ولكن انا مش حطلب الطلب ده لان الحداد كما
نعبر به عن الحزن فهو دافع
للنسيان وانا لا اريد ان انسى ولا اريدكم
ان تنسوا وشهد الحفل تكريم المخرج المصري
مروان حامد عن من جزه الابداعي في السينما
وتفتح الدوره السادسه من مهرجان الجونا
السينمائي نافذه على فلسطين من خلال
برنامج خاص بالسينما
الفلسطينيه وبمشاركه اكثر من 200 فنان
عربي وعالمي من بينهم ويل سميث ترافيس سكت
عمرو دياب حميد الشاعري حكيم محمود
العسيلي وروبي شهدت الرياضه الاسبوع
الماضي النسخه الرابعه من ساوند ستورم
الذي يوصف بانه اكبر مهرجان للموسيقى في
الشرق الاوسط امتد لثلاثه ايام واقيمت
فعالياته على ثمانيه مسارح وذلك قبل تعليق
الحفلات الغنائيه لثلاثه ايام في موسم
الرياض حدادا على امير الكويت الراحل
الشيخ نواف الاحمد الجابر الصباح بحسب ما
اعلنت الحسابات الرسميه للموسم على منصات
التواصل وفي دبي وقبل الاعلان عن الحداد
احيت احلام واصاله معا حفلا جماهيريا
وخلال الحفل كشفت اصاد للجمهور بطريقتها
الطريفه المعهوده عن جنس مولود ابنتها شام
قائله بين اليوم وبكره رح يجيني بنت جديده
بنت لشام وطالبت الجمهور بالدعاء لها
بالسلامه وهذا افسد على ما يبدو مفاجاه
شام للجمهور حيث نشرت صورتين لها عبر
حسابها الرسمي على انستغرام علقت عليها
بالقول يا ترى بنت ولا ولد اكيد صوله
عرفتكم شيرين تؤكد لبرنامج الحكايه طلقها
من حسام حبيب وفي اخر العام كما في مطلع
ديسمبر 2021 اكدت المطربه المصريه شيرين
عبد الوهاب انفصالها عن حسام حبيب بعد
سلسله من الازمات العاصفه بين الثنائي
شيرين كانت قد عادت لاستئناف نشاطها الفني
مطلع العام 2023 بحفل في الكويت غالبت فيه
دموعها
[موسيقى]
مش ووجدت طريقها للحل في نزاعها القضائي
مع روتانا كما قدمت سلسله من الحفلات في
السعوديه ظهرت فيها بحال افضل كنت روحي
لما كان قوه يا
روح عمري ما
تخيلت انك يوم
[موسيقى]
تروح خبر طلاق شيرين عبد الوهاب وحسام
حبيب لم يكن الوحيد عن انفصال ثنائيات
شهيره في مصر والعالم العربي خلال العام
الحالي حيث تم الاعلان خلال 2023 عن
انفصال الفنان المصري تامر حسني عن بسمه
بوسيل وذلك بعد اشهر من احتفالهما معا
ببدايه العام باداء مناسك العمره كما
اعلنت الفنانه المصريه هنا الزاهد
انفصالها عن الفنان المصري احمد فهمي
واعلن الفنان المصري يوسف الشريف مؤخرا
انفصاله عن انجي علاء في بيان مشترك عبر
حساباتهما الرسميه على منصات التواصل وبعد
سلسله النجاحات التي حققها في العام 203
صدم جمهور المطرب المصري احمد سعد باعلان
مصممه الازياء علياء بسيوني انفصال عنه
برغبه منه بحسب قولها وسط ظروف عائليه
صعبه مرت بها ووجهت له كلاما لاذعا وسخر
سعد من اتهامه بالنرجسيه خلال تسلمه جائزه
افضل اغنيه عربيه من ميوركس دور في بيروت
اسمحولي اتكلم عن نفسي بس شويه عشان انا
نسيت اخذ الدوا بتاع النرجسيه وعالميا
انفصلت نجمه البوب الامريكيه المثيره
للجدل بريتني سبيرز عن سام
اصغري